hi everyone I'm Erin Flynn general
manager here at Bioware
I'm excited to show you a glimpse of how
Mass Effect Andromeda is taking the
power of frostbite to new heights on the
Sony Playstation deal platform before we
get started if you're not watching this
in a 4k screen find one come back our
game is going to look fantastic on
whatever platform you choose to play on
but this video was meant to be
experienced in 4k 4k allows the game to
take on new levels of depth making Mass
Effect more immersive than ever now
sunlight no water they should all be
dead what you're seeing here is a very
small slice of the gaming development
everything here is in-game captured
directly from a PlayStation neo during
pre alpha we selected the segment's
specifically to showcase some of the
ways that neo will bring our
environments and characters to life like
never before more rounded remember they
don't you're nasty unless you get too
close
beyond higher resolutions we will offer
high dynamic range lighting on supported
platforms that means every detail will
come to life with a sense of depth
richness and realism that simply hasn't
been possible in the past well you look
at that wow I really watches grudging
surface
feel that this whole platforms resident
something
what be closed
no question this is the heart of the
fall
we leave you now with a cutscene where
you can really see our characters up
close be sure to tune in on november
seventh when will premiere our brand new
trailer and officially open the doors to
the next chapter of the Mass Effect
universe
is that the Helius cluster yeah there we
are all these points could be vaults
under the world's dormant like this one
Hey look there the whole place is
lighting up how our readings are off the
chart really off the chart but if it's
back online we should be good
you
[Music]